what have you seen in your data on
the family structure
driving
weak and strong men and what's called
weak and strong relationships with one's
masculinity what's really interesting
is that we often frame girls as being
the vulnerable gender right we often
frame conversations around like
protecting
uh our children like protecting our
girls we're not protective of boys and
what we find in the data
that that i find really uh important for
for us to talk about as a society is
that in many ways boys are actually more
vulnerable than girls when you look at
um for example
certain areas that have less resources
you know boys and girls are hurt by you
know we we see the data in the united
states how your zip code defines you
know so many other things but for boys
it is worse and girls will be able to
adapt and fare better in low uh resource
environments than than boys are so boys
are are actually really vulnerable we
need to be just as curious about the way
that we can protect boys
as we are interested in protecting girls
and and by the way when we protect boys
it protects girls because to your point
most
[ __ ]
yeah or because of men so it's like
let's just you know men are the first
victims of patriarchy
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks the future
of this is your host the future of zach
rauman thank you for taking the time to
tune in today
we have an episode that i'm particularly
passionate about
today we have liz planck on to talk
about the future of masculinity which is
something different than the topics
we've been talking about but in my
opinion imperative
to where we're going as a society and
specifically what liz talks about is how
we reevaluate our relationship
both men and women our relationship with
masculinity how we understand that i'm
particularly very very excited about it
but a few things first we dive in a
couple housekeeping things number one
the plan was to do a 12-week series
limited series on the future of and i
have good news based on the feedback i'm
getting we're going to extend this
so the future of not going anywhere
i know some of you are very worried
we're going to keep it going probably
through the end of june the plan is to
the end of june another few weeks and
then lots of exciting stuff coming down
the pike for yang speak so thank you all
for tuning in
we will continue to deliver
great content for you to listen to
second thing is monday we're celebrating
our 100th episode we're doing a mailbag
um so if you go on instagram even but
twitter mainly um but either of those
i'm gonna check
and andrew would check and use the
hashtag ask yangspeaks one word hashtag
askgangspeaks let us know your questions
we're going to get to as many as we can
so those are our housekeeping items and
now i want to set up this episode liz
planck
author journalist influencer and a very
very
hardcore feminist but this episode in
particular my dad um i grew up my dad
was really involved in men's ministry um
with our church growing up um so i'm
extremely passionate about this i'm
extremely passionate about how you set
up a society that creates strong men
and
i grew up thinking gender and our
relationship with masculinity was a
simple thing and the older i get
uh the more
i realize how complicated it is and
particularly for men how complicated our
own relationships are with what it means
to be a man and
liz where i've always respected liz and
agreed with liz on is that she believes
we need to focus more on men because
strong men treat women well
and weak men
harm women
or don't appreciate it don't respect
them and we need a society that creates
and and um
values strong men
and values men and encourages men to
respect women and that's what i'm
excited about how we do that because i
believe it's essential i think tom
brokaw said this at an event i once went
to said that
the u.s has only tapped into half of
their half of the country's potential
because it's been just led by men for
for decades and decades so i'm excited
where this future is going but men have
a role to play we have a long way to go
as a society and i'm excited and i was
really excited to learn from liz and
talk to liz about what this means so
tune in guys this went on a ramble but
this episode is something i'm very
passionate about the future of
masculinity liz planck joins right now
on yang speaks
[Music]
all right it is my
joy
right now to talk about the future of
masculinity with someone
i got to know on the presidential trail
who
comes at the same problem and some
somewhat the same solution but a
completely different way it's my like
absolute honor to welcome now recurring
guest on yang speaks
journalist author
producer influencer what else are you
you're just a general badass liz plank
welcome to gang speaks
thank you so much
am i a friend of the pod like are we
like am i is that your friend of the pod
now i'm a friend oh my god that's major
that's major i can't i feel honored that
we made it this far so when we met you
were
i no idea who you were you were kind of
a big deal but i didn't know like we did
so many interviews i had no clue and
then um
i remember like i posted online a photo
of you and andrew like a quick video of
you guys talking and i had like three or
four friends of mine be like are you
with liz planck right now and i was like
uh yeah if that's liz plank
yes i am um
and now so i've gotten to know you and
you
are
very very vocal
um and a very very passionate feminist
but you hit it differently almost
controversially in some circles
and you
focus on female empowerment you focus on
all of the things that a traditional
quote-unquote feminist is talking about
but you also
focus on
men and empowering
like let's say
the concept of weak men is what i'm
passionate about like i think a lot of
the problems that we're looking at in
terms of what is hurting women the most
i think weak men
are at the top of the list and i'm very
very passionate about um
how societies can create weak men how do
we how do we get there um so i want to
dive into all of this but let's start a
little bit like a bit
because you've been in a lot of
different types of production not
everything you've done has been geared
in this topic but you found your way
there so tell me a little about your
background and how you wrote this book
for love of men which is like a feminist
take on
how we need to like basically
get men to be better at not being so
weak and um so let's
tell me a little about your background
how you got into this list yeah
so my background is i
thought i was gonna i was enrolled for a
master's in social work in in montreal i
i thought that was you know gonna be my
my path and then i woke up the morning
of my
of my program and i was like i don't
think this is what i meant to do and so
i ended up uh day one
on yes and i canceled i lost like a
couple hundred bucks but they did refund
me
uh and my mother was mortified uh and
and but i ended up doing a masters in
policy work right so i i really thought
uh and and i was working with people
with disabilities at the time at a
community center and a if you watch
crypt camp at a camp that's very similar
to [ __ ] camp uh and what i found really
frustrating just in general also
regarding women but regarding all
marginalized sort of communities is that
in my day-to-day job i you know could do
as much there's only so much i could do
as a community counselor and and i felt
like as a social worker so i wanted to
go into policy to maybe work in
government or i don't even know like i
literally just was like okay this makes
sense i started writing when i was doing
my master's in london and i started this
campaign around like female boxers and
skirts and it's like a whole thing and
that's how i got my first article
published and then i just started
writing and i was like oh wait a minute
uh wow media is a whole
beast and i can
really uh write about things and not
just have like a professor put it in his
recycling bin at the end of the day but
like actually you know
find my tribe and find people to talk
about these things with and actually
impact change so i uh ended up
and i was you know really specializing
in women's studies and and gender uh
particularly and again gender equals
women in most of our brains when
actually what started happening as i was
uh you know and i was a reporter at vox
at mike that's how we came to know each
other uh i was reporting on you know
politics and on on the campaign trail
and just you know i i was just noticed
noticing that
it's great to talk about these things
with women and i would find myself in
rooms filled with women and have having
incredible conversations about freedom
and liberty but then i'd be like
wait a minute
like no wonder we haven't really moved
the needle in terms of gender equality
and feminism uh i think enough uh if if
half of us are missing right and so as i
started doing research uh for this book
for the love of men i you know first of
all without plugging at all enough
i don't know it's like i don't know it's
good it's good it's hiding uh all of the
mess in my room
let's be honest we might show we might
do a reveal at the end we might do a
reveal
we will not um
so
two things happened i start talking to
men about feminism
and um and and talking to men about
gender and realizing oh my god there is
so much happening with men in
relationship with their gender just like
there is with women in their gender
women have all kinds of stories
experiences right uh ideals models that
were pushed on them uh rethinking the
way that they are as women in the world
right women have been thinking about
this for you know
so long and men
i realized i was the first person to ask
them you know what does it mean to be a
man to you uh is being a man different
for you than it was for your father um
is there anything that you feel pressure
to do or act and say and and it was just
so incredible and then the second thing
that happened is i did a lot of research
and then i felt kind of betrayed by my
own
discipline
where i was like okay i've
spent so much money
educating myself when it comes to gender
and when it comes to gender equality why
has
why didn't anyone tell me how much men
benefit
from all of this right like we know it's
beneficial to women but like holy crap
you know men in feminist societies and
gender equal societies live longer right
iceland is this perfect example of this
feminist utopia just google iceland and
women and you'll find all these
different examples of why women are
better off in a country like iceland
that has the highest level of gender
equality but then i started researching
what how are the men doing and you know
according to sean hannity and tucker
carlson we would think that they would
be doing horribly under a feminist
dictatorship and so i ended up going to
iceland and trying to save men from
feminism and bring them back to america
where they're safe and none of them
wanted to come to america right they
were like i love my parental leave i
love my health care i love having more
sex and living longer right so um
there's so many positive impacts from
feminism
that we that we that really benefit
everybody that we just we know when we
only talk about it in terms of women
we're actually limiting the conversation
so let me i'll get real bit i'm this is
something i'm very very passionate about
because my dad
probably should have been a youth pastor
he was very involved in um particularly
men's ministry at my church growing up
and so i've seen the men's conferences
and frankly my whole life have seen
damaged men
and sometimes their sons and how they
pass that down and what
happens when they don't feel strong or
they don't feel like they have a purpose
and
and then if you look at the numbers um
who is causing the biggest problems to
women and to men by the way he's causing
problems to other men as well yeah sure
yes and actually in your book you said
there's no greater threat to humankind
than our current definition of
masculinity which i think is saying the
same thing
so why is our current definition of
masculinity a threat and i'll preface
this by saying
i don't know how much i'm going to
fundamentally agree with you i'm really
excited i want to learn from you
um because i think your perspective is
frankly what men need here so what yeah
what did you mean when you said that
yeah i mean i guess my first question is
also like you know how do we define weak
men right and and i think in our society
how we define weak men is often the ones
that are strong right so a man who
uh for example
yeah is with a group of men and there's
a sexist joke or there's a racist joke
or whatever it is and he's like hey
that's like not cool he's gonna be like
okay he's gonna be called you know a
[ __ ] he's gonna be called whatever
right and he's gonna be uh seen as
non-masculine when actually what takes
bravery what takes courage what takes uh
you know being non-conventional is
actually going against the grain of that
sort of misogyny so so i think that's
like an interesting tension there you're
right the premise of my weak men is
actually
should be up for debate or like that
that premise needs to change a bit well
but i think it's a it's it's a good
framing right so because
too often and and this is how i'm going
to answer your question and and also
touch on that which is
if we look at vaccines for example and
the covid pandemic and who's getting
vaccines and who's not getting vaccines
we have seen now research throughout the
pandemic showing that men are you know
less likely to wear masks they're less
likely to wash their hands there was
less likely to social distance they're
less likely to be in support of you know
uh states having lockdowns
right and rules and so but what's really
interesting is that there's recent data
that i wrote about from a column on
msnbc
which actually makes a difference of
like but which men right because it's
not all men hashtag right and i'm using
this in a positive feminist way not the
way that it's you know often used to
derail conversations about feminism but
it is
in the study that they actually tried to
make a difference between men and how
they identify with their masculinity
right that and so they asked men do you
identify as very masculine somewhat
masculine not masculine at all or like
do you not care
and this is the fascinating bit i like
lit like this is one of the cool i i had
like a a a like
nerd orgasm like when i read this okay
okay
what's so fascinating is that
when we look at men who are hostile to
the vaccine men who are hostile men
who've been gathering with groups of
more than 10 people
it's the men who identify as very or
completely masculine when you look at
men who don't they are acting actually
you can't tell the difference between
women and men so it is not men's
biological gender that determines their
behavior it is their relationship with
their gender that determines their
behavior and attitudes right and so to
me
that's where
it's that definition right because we
define masculinity in a certain way and
men who ascribe to that cultural uh
definition which is being pushed down
their throats and being you know
rewarded on all kinds of ways in our
cultural artifacts in our political
system right the men who ascribe to that
end up being not just a danger to other
people but a danger to themselves right
they're if you're not getting
vaccinating you're or you're you're you
know not wearing a mask i mean not only
are you uh is it disrespectful to other
people it's also putting you at risk
and this is not just one this is one
example i
i cite many in the book about you know
uh from from wearing a condom during sex
uh men who are more again identify with
these more masculine prototypically
masculine characteristics um are less
likely to practice safe sex they're more
likely to uh not respect traffic lights
right like get into accidents there's so
many different ways that we see this
play out and so that's why i i didn't
say men are the greatest threat
to our society it's our definition of
masculinity that's the greatest threat
that we need to disrupt and encourage
men to liberate themselves from
[Music]
this episode of yank speaks is brought
to you by better help
i love better help oh my gosh i do it
once a week my therapist my her fake
name is sarah because i don't wanna i
don't know still's wrong maybe tell her
real name because it's supposed to be
confidential with me but anyway it's
amazing i can go online i go and i
register i pick i can do video i can
chat i can chat her anytime it's awesome
you can start communicating so fast like
under 48 hours it's not a crisis line
it's not self-help it's just
professional counseling done securely
online so you can talk to your counselor
i talk to sarah all the time it's
fantastic you can get it all over the
world and you get licensed professional
counselors that match with you depending
on what you're looking for whether
you're coping with depression or stress
anxiety relationships grief self-esteem
for me it's just like i need help with
figuring out the direction of the world
navigating what is going on out there we
try to do that on the pod but better
help is there too i really really can't
stress enough how important it is to get
your
thoughts and motions out there to talk
to somebody it's great so here's the
deal
i want you to start living a happier
life today and as a listener of yank
speak you'll get 10 off your first month
by visiting our sponsor betterhelp.com
yang join over one million people have
taken charge of their mental health like
me
and andrew we got this that's
dot betterhelphelp.com slash yang
[Music]
that weakness that lack of
understanding that being a man is not
just dominating a conversation or not
looking at women as an up women as an
object and that like sense of
what it means to be a man is not
to me it has to be taught and it comes
to me
down to the relationship probably
um with their father um who was your
model of masculinity and manhood
as a child and if you look at the
numbers united states where half i think
it's half of marriages end up in divorce
right now and uh it's 40 of of kids are
born as single parents mostly single
mothers and they don't have a father
figure or they they always pick one and
you never know what you're getting in
that sense because you're a child and
you're latching on what have you seen in
your data on
the family structure
driving
weak and strong men and that's called
weak and strong relationships with one's
masculinity
it's incredibly impactful obviously look
we're all
sort of little miniature versions of our
childhood selves just like playing
adults right so our development in the
first five years especially is is
extremely hard to deprogram right so
whatever attention or neglect or abuse
right um uh you you you experience at
that time or absence right will will
impact you and what's really interesting
is that we often frame girls as being
the vulnerable gender right we often
frame conversations around like
protecting
uh our children like protecting our
girls right from abuse from pregnancy or
teen pregnancy right we're very
protective of girls
and
we're not protective of boys we actually
often see that parents um and again this
is not i think women and men do this but
i think men feel like it's their
responsibility to discipline boys right
and to make sure that they're not soft
and that they're you know that they can
protect not be protected and what we
find in the data
that that i find really uh important for
for us to talk about as a society is
that in many ways boys are actually more
vulnerable than girls when you look at
um for example
certain areas that have less resources
where there's more poverty right or or
in a school where there's literally
again like a lower income neighborhood
or there's less uh resources in their
particular
educational opportunities
you know boys and girls are hurt by you
know we we see the data in the united
states how your zip code defines you
know so many other things but for boys
it is worse and girls will be able to
adapt and fare better in low uh resource
environments than than boys are this is
not to say that girls don't need uh the
same stuff but but boys and and one
other piece of data that's i think
really relevant and that relates to
fatherhood is you know ma the mass
incarceration problem that we have in
this country where you know black and
brown fathers are literally not allowed
to parent 91 of parents who are in jail
currently are fathers so the mass
incarceration conversation is a
fatherhood conversation and so what we
also find is that again having a parent
who's incarcerated is extremely
impactful in in negative ways for
children but again
we see it uh we see it for girls but it
is worse when for boys in terms of their
behavioral um
you know
sort of changes in the way that they are
will be less likely to finish school so
boys are are actually really vulnerable
and boys
you need to be treated with the same
level we need to be just as curious
about the way that we can protect boys
as we are interested in protecting girls
and and by the way when we protect boys
it protects girls because to your point
mostly
[ __ ]
yeah or because of men so it's like
let's just you know men are the first
victims of patriarchy like they're
victimized by it and then they victimize
women and that's not a classic male
thing to think we're the victim in some
i mean no you you think you win in the
system but it's a it's a pyramid scheme
like who wins like one percent
and then the rest don't they just
constantly try and climb up the ladder
but they're not able to achieve any of
the rewards
so one of the stats we would uh andrew
and i would cite it's in his book um the
war on home people was called the book
um but he would talk about um
[Music]
what happens when men and women lose
their jobs
and
so the job and particularly in older
generations
the job was not just your job it was
your livelihood your purpose you are the
provider you're the man you're the
breadwinner whatever definition but
there's some a lot of identity
associated with it particularly for men
and the numbers bear that out when women
lose their jobs they generally stay like
their behavior doesn't really change
they stay productive they either become
more caretakers in the home or they join
non-profits or they get involved in
school and they essentially stay flat in
terms of their overall well-being and
productivity men disintegrate men turn
to by the numbers um
video games alcohol sometimes drugs and
pornography
and suicide
yeah yes they get and then um they get
depressed and um so very very serious
mental health issues and suicide how
have you seen that the element of
strength play in and i really want to
dive in because there's also emotional
strength too which i think women
are based on what you're talking about
probably stronger emotionally than men
um so there's two different types of
strength here how much that
responsibility kind of weighs in on
people's relationship with their their
gender i guess yeah i mean that's a
really interesting question feminism and
gender equality actually acts as a
buffer for male suicide okay
because what we find throughout history
is exactly what you're saying uh when
there's economic crises when a lot of
people lose their jobs and particularly
uh kobit was the first actually
extremely unequal recession in history
where women were the most hurt but if
you look at 2008 for example the last
recession we had men lost a lot of jobs
right um women did too but manufacturing
jobs right like when we think about the
jobs that were that were really lost um
a lot of men lost their jobs right and
so what happens is
normally you have an increase in male
suicide right when you have uh
higher unemployment with men because of
everything that you've said
but when you have a society where women
actually contribute equally right that
it's not just men or the breadwinner and
women stay at home that women are the
breadwinner too
male and female suicide rates are not as
skewed
and that's because you know the thing
you can infer from that
which the researcher who studied this
inferred this is you know
yeah when you put that all of that
burden on one person and on one gender
and that
and it's also on something that you
cannot control i mean the both of us
could lose our jobs tomorrow right this
is not something that's you know you
earn right it's out of your control but
if if if the only thing that makes you a
man
is being a breadwinner and that that's
no longer available to you of course
you're gonna think that you're a burden
of course you're gonna think that you're
there's nothing good that you can do
you're gonna have an uh a crisis of
identity and that's what we're seeing
men experience and and in and again it's
like if we could degender working if we
could degender uh bread winning as as an
identity and
uh by doing that give men more
flexibility and possibility and
imagination about how to be men in
society and how to be useful or you know
what their purpose can be
like then you have such an expansive
opportunity and and you have men who
aren't as
uh
you know completely distraught and and
and destroyed if they lose their jobs um
and so i i think so much about that
about how
um
you know these roles are made up well
these roles are just like you know again
we can go back into capitalism and all
stuff but like literally like these were
just inventions like
you know
women of color have always worked like
like it wasn't a thing like it was just
like a white working-class model right
of the nuclear family that men work and
women rockwell painting whatever it is
yeah exactly and so if we were to sort
of
just give people more flexibility when
it comes to that it would just make
everyone you know
much happier um and i just i get so sad
you know to think that a man would feel
like a burden because you know he's not
able to
to provide and also providing you know
women provide by doing all kinds of
things right like even if we think about
prototypical like a stay-at-home dad or
mom is providing oh my god like that's
providing care
and she worked harder than my dad in
many ways exactly it's just more
valuable community than my father did in
my dad nothing against my dad um my
dad's ministry or you know the church's
ministry that i grew up in or wherever
he is one of the things like the most
common things you've got all we bring
all these men together which is great it
would be called my dad does one called
iron sharpens iron which is a bible
verse like iron sharpens iron a one man
sharp another which i do think like
brotherhood and sisterhood i think are
really important for particularly for
men to actually talk about this stuff um
but
one of the things like the most common
thing we get at these it's wild is that
um
the men say their wives nag them um does
she's nagging me she's telling me to
take the trash out tell me you're not
doing this and
what my dad and the the conference would
say to the guys and i want your opinion
on whether this is
healthy or counter and counterproductive
to what we're talking about here because
this is where i think the devil's in the
details and stuff what they would say at
the church would be
well she's what is she nagging you to do
what the question is and well she wants
to take the trash out she wants to make
the bed he's like well um
if are you the man of the house like yes
like well whose job is it to make sure
the house is looking good he's like it's
my job like yes so like what is she
nagging to do bud she's not gonna do
your job i'm like thank god she's there
because it sounds like you wouldn't
[ __ ] do it so
michael and like when we tell men this
we being like the the the leaders of
this um a light bulb goes off um and to
me i always felt like it was shifting
their definition of masculinity where i
don't have to be like yeah ra rao you
get that for me
it's like no i'm actually here to
help and support you and and some
protection some love some like but it
like a responsibility piece thoughts on
that like how off base is that church in
florida talking about that at the moment
i think that's wonderful and again it's
like
i think it's such a great way to frame
this conversation right that again i
just want to de-gender
[ __ ] like i just want to de-gender like
like yeah keeping your home clean like
that should just be something you do
period like like not something that
anyone has to yeah like ask you to do
because their gender is right and and
you find this with um lgbtq couples lgbt
lgbtq couples are just have high levels
really higher levels of satisfaction in
their relationships than straight
couples because there's no norm it's
like who fits
if this is what the man is supposed to
do and it's two women yes it's just like
what do you like to do and you know it's
our house and how are we going to
there's just a more equitable separation
of of work because there's not
predetermined rules that are made up by
who the [ __ ] knows and um and and
there's more freedom right it's all
about freedom like truly it is about
freedom and you know with your example
the other thing i was just thinking
about which really again is such a it's
such a detriment to our society that we
consistently
um are trained not to listen to women
and not to believe women and to blame
women like we blame women for everything
and it is so again i mean there's
examples of you know we blame women for
their own sexual assault like it we
blame women for right like not smiling
enough and talks about being dehuman
where you look you don't look at women
as as equal exactly human it's a
dehumanization that needs to be taught
you know what i'm saying like i think
it's biologically if you're just caveman
i don't think that boys are like that
though like i don't think that there's
something natural again it comes back to
the research separating you know and i
think we need more research that that
asks these nuanced questions that
instead of seeing men as a monolith you
know is interested in how they you know
yeah what they believe about masculinity
and how that ends up determining a lot
of different things like like i think we
we assume certain biologic we did this
with women right we assumed women were
just kinder and on their periods and
more emotional and it's like these
things are so wrong like emotional do
you want to get you want to talk about
how like every war like it's like in
history like and and this is not to say
again that women are more specific but
but we've we've created you know our
society creates certain rules certain
norms certain scripts and then we follow
them and then it's like
i want people to to to be interested in
figuring out who they are authentically
right and maybe it means that yeah
you're a go-getter and you are you have
more of an aggressive personality right
in in that way and like that's who you
are there are women who are like that
like it's fine but is that really who
you are or are you playing a part and
and when it comes to again just
listening to women that's the you know i
think everyone wants
something that like a marriage that
doesn't end in divorce like i think no
one's like in it to like divorce but the
number one uh factor that leads to a
lasting marriage heterosexual marriage
is a man that accepts his wife's
influence okay and this is from the
gottman institute they've done
years and years of research on this and
it's very simple right it just means
when she says something you listen when
she says something you you you don't say
no you're wrong or oh you're making
things up like the way that we talked
about women in our society
[Music]
the world is opening up again we can go
outside again so whether you're working
or playing a lot of us can be on the
move this summer and my advice to you
take your raycon earbuds with you
so a pair raycon wireless earbuds in
your years make all the difference in
what you're doing when we're finally
getting outside this summer you get
crisp powerful beats at half the price
of all the other premium audio brands
they look great they feel even better
and they come in a range of cool colors
so with customizable gel tips intended
for a comfortable in-ear fit and they're
built to go wherever you go with a quick
seamless bluetooth pairing and compact
charging case it's pretty freaking
awesome i could take them anywhere throw
them in my bag don't a suitcase throw in
the pockets so this is the deal
raycon's offering 15 off all their
products for our listeners and here's
what you've got to do to get it go to
buy raycon dot com slash yang you'll get
15 off your entire recon order
it's an awesome deal you'll want to grab
a pair and a spare that's 15 off buy
raycon.com yang that's byracon.com
[Music]
in teaching men
to be an actual strong man which
actually requires them to be weaker in a
lot of ways weaker in terms of the
traditional definition of masculinity
and women the same way almost like to be
a little more masculine in some ways in
terms of being more assertive and more
empowered and more confident can you go
too far
in one direction when you're trying to
like you're talking about like flipping
the script and redefining a lot of stuff
so first of all yeah chinese medicine
chinese philosophy the the yin and the
yang is literally like the feminine and
the masculine right
equally yoked is the biblical version of
that yeah exactly and it's all about you
know how we all have feminine and
masculine energy and and and things have
masculine and feminine energy right
there's like all kinds of
and and we've accepted that for women
and again it's more for you know we
accepted more with white women with the
more privileged you are the more you can
be like you know dress up like a man and
no one cares and it's not the same for
you know different kinds of women and
and again you know marginalization will
play into that uh but generally speaking
there's just a much more of an of an
acceptance of women who that we accept
that women can be masculine and feminine
i mean we can wear pants literally like
no one you know but you can't wear a
dress if you show up and you wear a
dress it's like oh my god like harry
styles on the cover of vogue like high
heels was invented by men for men right
like they were met at four men in 1600
persia like so that it was to get on
your horse and ride your horse more
easily they were like oh if we put heels
and so men wore high heels right like
all of these things like even like if
you look at you know robes right and and
and
what did jesus wore a dress right like
jesus deserves to wear a dress all day
long
not sacrilegious folks it's um reality
he also wasn't white don't forget that
yeah that too that's a big combo but men
showing any kind of feminine energy is
seen as taking away from their
masculinity right it's seen as like well
if you have feminine energy then you
can't be masculine whereas whereas like
women can wear pants and still be
considered feminine so so it's about you
know and that comes from misogyny right
that comes from the feminine being the
worst thing that a man can be because a
woman is the worst thing that you can
you know is is at the lowest ranking
position and so if we celebrate
femininity if we celebrate women then
we wouldn't be as afraid of men showing
characteristics of women we'd be like
look up to women look how great they are
you can be like them right in the way
that we do that with with girls right
that they can be bosses and badasses and
engineers and take on these masculine
role quote unquote masculine rules and
and sort of responsibilities um we
should be we should if we didn't hate
women
right if we didn't diminish the feminine
then it wouldn't be it would be fine for
men to show it
carly your girlfriend calls it the soft
bigotry of low expectations where i i
always see it it's like it's like the
silent killer where it's like no one in
wall street is going on be like screw
you screw the women right no one's
saying that they're just silent i've
realized particularly in wall street
like looking back was like the young
ambitious talented women that were
coming in and like look i've been there
five six years and they're right out of
college like that's like the age gap
they would ask like hey do you um
you've been a mentor to me zach but also
would like to find a female mentor here
at the company of course
and there weren't many to pick from
there was just a handful and it was i'm
curious about this application in the
workplace and like look i think a number
of women believe to to have children and
and i love that i think we should have
workplaces that are more flexible to um
not separate church and state in that
sense they shouldn't be mutually
exclusive um but curious on
like how this plays out in the real
world right in your eyes because i've
seen it and it's just like this
it's like unspoken expectation that the
women that do well here have to act like
the dudes um yeah that's the culture and
again it comes back to you know because
we devalue the feminine in order for
women to be successful they have to be
masculine right or they have to take on
these masculine characteristics and
erase their femininity um and and again
it comes from this yeah made up thing
where like masculinity is better and
it's like why and women are so much
better and then it's so many things and
we all know it we have to pretend it's
not like we have to dig up some studies
that are ambiguous it's obvious right
yeah um so and and workplaces are better
when everyone's at the table like even
if when we talk about for example i mean
we know having women in your boardroom
having women
having a seat at the table it just means
that you make better decisions there's
more creativity there's a higher
productivity and there's a higher bottom
line but even if you look at you know
disability the fact that we totally uh
discriminate against people with
disabilities uh in our society means
that they're just
completely inv erased from from most
workplaces and industries but what we
find is that there you know there was a
accenture study actually that found that
workplaces that did take a commitment to
include disability into their diversity
uh initiatives and programs had a higher
bottom line and there's i'm sure
yeah it makes sense for a profit
perspective like more like different
views more diverse views you can make
that's the thing and you'll serve more
people like a quarter of the population
is disabled if you have no people with
disabilities in the room like
you you there's [ __ ] you could sell to
them like you know there's a
capitalistic obviously you know uh
argument here yeah but your [ __ ]
capitalist in me says you should
probably have more women at the table
um it's just like everyone wins
um so so yeah i think i think we i think
again it's like it's not about telling
men act more like women it's not about
telling women to act more like men it's
just like letting everyone be who the
[ __ ] they want to be right and like
letting everyone become letting our
children become who they are and like
instead of this version right that they
think that they're supposed to be that's
just the
you know i think so much we talk so much
about the the missed potential of women
right and like you know what if the girl
that could have come up with a cure for
cancer you know had not got you know
been pushed to to go into stem and i'm
like well what if the boy who you know
would be this incredible nurse that
could you know heal all these people
didn't go into nursing because his dad
was like that's not a real job for you
you have to do something else or or
teachers right like the impact on black
boys in our country of just having a
black male teacher you know and and
and it's only two percent of teachers
are black black men so we're seeing you
know coming back to education it's so
important and could have such huge
ripple effects if everyone could just
fulfill their potential as humans
instead of as men or women so
gender i've learned gender is
complicated and i grew up thinking i
grew up learning gender was simple right
so this has been a learning journey for
me um both myself like understanding
like what like i don't have to be that
type of man right but also
learning about a whole number of um
frankly others other journeys when a
child is starting to identify as the a
gender that's different than their
biological gender right like starting to
identify differently
as a parent what what's a good best
practice in terms of helping kids be
themselves and like letting this
education flourish in a new kind of
world you're talking about yeah i mean
that's a really really important
question especially as we're seeing
um you know 2020 was the worst year with
the most amount of anti-trans bills and
ever children who are questioning their
gender identity the biggest threat to
their lives is suicide okay because
they're already being told by everybody
right that there's something wrong with
them and so and they're being excluded
in all in in a wide variety of ways and
and it's the inner turmoil of having to
figure that out is already humongous
right and we know that trans kids
more than half of them have thought
about suicide and i just don't know if
people realize how harrowing that
statistic is and we know that um the
people who are are at the front lines of
fighting these bills are saying they're
getting calls from kids saying i'm going
to kill myself
so
the most important thing for children
and and one last bit of data
is that actually you know so there's you
know think different things you can do
before you're 18 and i understand these
are children and you know we we have
there are you know concerns about about
making sure that they're okay but
actually um it's called hormonal
suppression therapy so it just means
that we are suppressing their puberty it
doesn't mean that we're changing
anything it doesn't mean that we're
right making permanent changes but just
the fact of suppressing puberty
uh reduces suicide ideation
just across the board for these children
so we know based on the data right
that
what actually makes these children's
lives really hard is not the fact that
they're uh
you know trans or that they're gender
non-binary it is the way that society
is imposing uh you know certain
rigidities or or laws against them and
so the best thing that we can do i think
as parents is try and protect our
children right um and and the rest of
the world is going to eat them up right
like no matter i mean literally like i i
mean i tell this to my parents and i'm
i'm a sis i'm cisgender you know when my
parents are very critical i'm like you
know the whole world is gonna find
problems with this book like i don't
need you to tell me what's wrong with
with me i actually need you to tell me
what's right with me and so that would
be my advice for parents um who are who
are dealing with this and obviously i'm
not an expert on this but
um and there's so many amazing you know
i'm thinking of uh chase strangio and
alok and and thomas paige mcbee like you
know trans voices who are really uh
like
raquel willis who are leading the charge
with this and and i think are are
helping but it's really about education
you know and educating parents um to
understand that this is not the end of
the world
and you know this can be something that
you figure out privately and the
government should certainly not have uh
any role in in determining you know
these very private and personal
decisions for people correct me for
wrong it seems like the future of this
is
how parents relate this and model this
for their kids um and if that's broken
we
every problem we solve we're just going
to have 10x
more problems on the other side of this
i mean
what do you think yeah yeah and and the
more we let bills like this go by and we
don't stand up against them then then
parents do think that it's in their best
interest to prove you know protect their
children by denying their gender
identity right like like i it just
reminds me of like you know again coming
back to disability like the problem
often is not the disability it's the
ableism right like a person in a
wheelchair is is uh the barrier is not
their wheelchair it's the fact that like
the oscars right until this year didn't
have a ramp and it's like just make
better design right let's build a better
society instead of conf you know
confining our children to fit into it um
and and and and yeah i also think you
know for parents who are listening even
if you're cisgender like if they're
gonna start
pulling data on people's on children's
genitals like like they're gonna come
for you next like if we allow this is a
privacy issue like the fact that they're
pulled you know wanna
um you know have all this surveillance
of our private of our literal private
parts should scare everybody who cares
about privacy
like that's weird
oh very very weird i think what what
breaks my heart is like on these issues
when they get political we have yeah
essentially billions of dollars of ads
in messaging campaigns dividing us on
them but
putting people one way or another
when
the root problem is like we don't have a
very good public education system in
this country where like teachers are
well paid and happy and less stressed
and can love their kids and and have the
bandwidth to treat them all differently
right um like and individually um we
don't have uh
an infrastructure or like the economy
like the things that are
actually probably driving some of this
um
these changes or negative behavior um
like the root problems don't get
addressed and then we focus on these
let's call it quote-unquote symptoms
right of these culture wars and it's
heartbreaking um that we have these
conversations but i think frankly liz
someone like you
what you're doing to me is um
is massively important i think um it's
one of my passions in life is to figure
out how we empower a new generation of
men
to treat women well to believe that to
not be insecure when they're kicking
your ass at something to say like that's
freaking awesome because i'm great at
other things and it does my manhood and
my pride is not hurt or defined by the
success of my wife or my sister or the
women in my life
um
and to still feel strong
when women are strong that is like
there's been this like if i'm if i if
you're strong i have to be the weak one
i'm the you know um
and i hope
and i pray and i'm i'm grateful for
people like you just like all it takes
is just we got to keep changing
conversation just keep talking about it
i'm so grateful um when you come on i i
honestly i could i could talk about
three hours about this i don't know me
too
it's so great to see you and i loved
your stories i think it's it's really
useful to have
my biggest fear is that this
conversation stays in the bubble right
and and um i think it's really important
to think about the language that we're
using and how accessible it is um
and that accessibility is is not just in
terms of ramps but even accessibility in
terms of people who are different you
know differently educated differently
you know who are in different jobs and
different experiences and life
perspectives so i appreciate that and i
think the work you're doing is really
important creating that bridge thank you
thank you for the love of men is on sale
but we'll put the link in our bio guys
um
and frankly you can follow liz plank
anywhere tick tock all those things it's
wonderful thank you for joining go keep
kicking butt
thank you this is great
[Music]
you